wieder offene türen in vielen
bundesländern dürfen weitere läden
aufmachen die bundeskanzlerin mahnt aber
jetzt nicht zuviel zu fordern es wäre
jammerschade wenn wir sehenden auges in
einen rückfall gegen neustadt bei den
autobauern deutsche hersteller fahren
die produktion langsam wieder hoch und
fordern staatliche kaufprämien und
flammen alarm bei gummersbach wegen
eines waldbrands müssen anwohner in
sicherheit gebracht werden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber und amt in allen die
welt an diesem montag
es ist der beginn einer neuen woche in
der deutschland ganz langsam und mit
vielen unterschiedlichen kleinen
schritten versucht wieder hochzufahren
und gleichzeitig heftig diskutiert wie
angemessen das ist insbesondere für
geschäfte gibt es neue regeln nach denen
sie wieder öffnen dürfen allerdings je
nach bundesland durchaus
unterschiedliche und gleichzeitig warnt
die bundeskanzlerin vor einer diskussion
über zu viele lockerungen gucken wir uns
erstmal die neue situation heute an
wieder aufmachen dürfen geschäfte mit
einer fläche von bis zu 800
quadratmetern auto fahrrad sowie
buchhändler dürfen auch größer sein
allerdings warten bayern berlin
brandenburg und thüringen mit der
ladenöffnung noch ab dagegen erlaubt
nordrhein westfalen auch möbelhäusern
egal wie groß sie sind wieder zu
verkaufen
dieser montag in deutschlands
einkaufsstraßen thomas münten berichtet
bonn innenstadt nur für die ersten
kunden sind schon da während die
angebots waren noch aufgeschoben wird
hygiene hinweise über all die händler
sind vorbereitet
unsere verkäuferinnen müssen an der
maske tragen jeder kunde den laden
betritt kriegt unsere maske geschenkt
wir haben an allen beratungs ecken diese
sie ist den schutzscheiben aufgestellt
das wohlgefühl gut für die stimmung
düsseldorf nordstraße heute nachmittag
die straße ist gut besucht in den leben
aber zb in dieser boutique herrscht
große disziplin als bis jetzt jeder
stehen geblieben hat gefragt ob bahrain
darf baden württemberg auch in ulm
öffneten die läden heute erstmals nach
vier wochen einige händler fürchten dass
die zwangspause nicht mehr aufholbar ist
das war die frühjahrs hochsaison kunz
das heißt also wir haben über 4
wochenhoch setzungen umsatz verloren das
sind etwa 30 prozent des umsatzes
die kunden stimmung vor den läden
schwankt heute noch zwischen freude und
ungehalten ich bin optimistisch bleibe
ich auch so aber trotzdem vorsichtig es
ist aber andererseits sehr schön dass es
irgendwie wieder alles so lebendig für
gewissen sachen finde ich wichtig aber
die angst bleibt also ich würde jetzt
kein bummel machen durch die stadt bis
hinten wieder raus
jetzt ist ob das jetzt das richtige ist
wie sich die heutige ladenöffnung auf
die infektionszahlen auswirkt wird sich
erst in zwei wochen zeigen
politisch läuft die diskussion ob das
alles reicht oder ob das bereits zu viel
ist und was passiert wenn die virus lage
wieder dramatischer werden sollte aus
einer sitzung ihres cdu parteipräsidiums
wird die bundeskanzlerin so zitiert
öffnungs diskussions orgien erhöhten das
risiko eines rückfalls stark ein begriff
verdienen sie jetzt auch kritisiert wird
karl hinterleitner über die details der
debatte die strategie der kanzlerin sie
bleibt ein spagat den harten griff auf
das land langsam lockern die pandemie
aber gleichzeitig im griff behalten
im kampf gegen korona gibt es für angela
merkel nur zwischenergebnisse die
zerbrechlich sind die situation die wir
jetzt jeden tag haben sie ist eben
trügerisch denn das was wir heute
gewonnen haben die öffnung der läden auf
die wir uns auch gemeinsam geeinigt
haben was das bedeutet bezüglich der
infektionszahlen das sehen wir in 14
tagen und nicht vorher und das ist das
was die sache so schwierig macht
die sozialdemokraten unterstützen die
kanzlerin vorsicht und zurückhaltung
seien richtig für den erfolg in zukunft
entscheidend dass koalition aber auch
bund und länder weiter einig sind
das war eine grundlage dafür dass wir
auf allen ebenen gute entscheidungen
getroffen haben die den menschen
orientierung gegeben haben und deswegen
müssen wir uns jetzt wirklich vorsehen
wenn wir lockern wollen und auch in der
opposition bestreitet niemand wirklich
dass die beschränkungen sein müssen
aber man müsse sie öfter und besser
überprüfen
erklärungsbedürftig in unserem
freiheitlichen rechtsstaat ist die
einschränkung von grundrechten und nicht
deren ausübung insofern ist es geboten
das häufiger die grundrechtseingriffe
überprüft werden die kanzlerin hält
dagegen nichts sei schlimmer als
maßnahmen zu früh zurückzufahren
ich glaube ganz fest dass sozusagen die
verhinderung eines rückschritts dass wir
wieder zurückkehren müssen zu härteren
maßnahmen nicht nur im interesse der
bekämpfung der pandemie ist
sondern auch im interesse der
entwicklung unserer wirtschaft und des
gesellschaftlichen lebens politik in der
pandemie zeit entscheiden ohne die
folgen wirklich absehen zu können die
strategie der kanzlerin dabei gebremstes
tempo und sehr viel vorsicht für eine
analyse gehen wir jetzt live nach berlin
theropoden abend was es da im moment
hinter den kulissen der politik los im
grunde beginnt heute eine besonders
schwierige phase dieser pandemie
bekämpfung des modell wird ja gerne als
hammer und tanz beschrieben den hammer
hatten wir bis gestern also die zeit
fast vollständiger beschränkungen jetzt
beginnt quasi die phase des tanzes also
der lockerungen mit der gefahr von
erneuten aufwärtsbewegung bei den
infektionen wie in einer tanzenden
wellenbewegung und die offensichtliche
sorge hier in berlin hinter und bei
merkel ja heute auch sehr deutlich vor
den kulissen ist es zwar jeder die
methode hammer kann aber das tanzen
schwieriger ist auch als regierungskunst
daher heute die massive warnung der
kanzlerin vor zuviel lockerungen in
manchen ländern gucken wir mal auf die
länder jetzt kann man sagen
unterschiedliche situationen in den
einzelnen bundesländern das heißt dann
eben auch unterschiedliche regelungen
man kann aber auch sagen was soll wer
soll so ein flickenteppich überhaupt
noch verstehen ist das jetzt unter dem
strich eine sternstunde des föderalismus
was wir da erleben oder eher ein indiz
für kleinstaaterei also wie so oft ja
beide ist aber letzteres auf jeden fall
würde man heute ein wissensquiz
veranstalten also was in welchem
bundesland erlaubt ist und was nicht
ich glaube kaum jemand könnte das
umfassend beantworten da öffnet in
rheinland pfalz ein riesiges
einkaufszentrum im saarland nur ein paar
kilometer weiter wäre das nicht erlaubt
man kann das ganze positiv formulieren
als vorteil des föderalismus also dass
man unterschiedliche konzepte erproben
kann wie in einer art laborexperiment
und dann sieht was am besten
funktioniert aber im kern haben die
länder natürlich unterschiedliche
interessen nordrhein westfalen
beispielsweise ist die möbelindustrie
wichtig und daher ist dort die öffnung
großer möbelhäuser für die wirtschaft
wichtiger als beispielsweise in
baden-württemberg oder bayern wo die
autoindustrie eine ganz andere rolle
spielt
einig scheinen sich söder und laschet
heute gewesen zu sein
die fußball-bundesliga soll als
geisterspiele denkbar seien denkbar
vielen dank theo nach berlin manche
geschäfte jetzt also wieder offen in
deutschland wie der tag lief und was
virologen dazu sagen das können sie
gleich nach wohnen sind wiso spezial
sehen und in unserer zdf heute erklären
experten wie man emotional halbwegs
stressfrei durch die krisenzeit kommt
und wir bleiben noch beim thema und
haben jetzt wie immer den blick auf die
wichtigen zahlen dieser virus krise und
da schauen wir zunächst einmal auf die
neuinfektionen in deutschland die
schwanken nach wie vor aber der trend
ist positiv
anfang des monats gab es tage mit fast
7000 neuinfektionen
gestern waren es noch etwa 1800 stand
heute vor einer halben stunde sind laut
johns hopkins universität insgesamt mehr
als 100 46.000 infektionen durch tests
bestätigt davon gelten 51 1091 1500 als
genesen 4696 menschen starben in
verbindung mit dem corona virus eine
zentrale rolle im kampf gegen korona
sollen die gesundheitsämter übernehmen
beispielsweise infektionsketten
nachverfolgen um so die ausbreitung des
erregers unter kontrolle zu bringen
dafür gibt es jetzt mehr personal und
mehr geld 150.000 euro für jedes der
knapp 400 gesundheitsämter in vielen
ländern gehören mund nasen masken schon
zum gewohnten straßenbild und die setzen
sich jetzt mehr und mehr auch bei uns
durch viele bundesländer empfehlen sie
bayern und mecklenburg vorpommern
schreiben sie ab kommender woche in
geschäften und in bussen und bahnen vor
in sachsen gelten diese vorschriften
bereits seit heute weil ja weitere
geschäfte wieder aufmachen sollen sie
vor allem auch das personal dort vor
ansteckung schützen
beim thema krankschreibung per telefon
ein hin und her der neueste stand wer
leichter atemwegserkrankungen hat kann
sich doch weiterhin per telefon
krankschreiben lassen für eine woche
das gilt jetzt erst mal bis ende
vergangener woche war die
ausnahmeregelung beendet wurden vor
allem ärzte hatten das wegen des
ansteckungsrisikos in den praxen heftig
kritisiert seit wochen geht nichts mehr
in den deutschen autowerken das virus
hat die produktion lahmgelegt die
gesamte branche ist mitten drin in der
krise bei den neuzulassungen in europa
bereits im märz ein minus von 52 prozent
heute nun ein erster kleiner schritt
nach vorn in einigen deutschen werken
geht es wieder los
den anfang macht der daimler-konzern
mehr von ihrer schüler wählten haben wir
so viele glückliche gesichter beim
schichtwechsel gesehen
nach vier wochen stillstand öffnet
daimler unter anderen das werk in
gaggenau wieder in dem mitarbeiter
getriebe fertigen
ja es ist doch befreiendes gefühl
leichter umgesetzt hier wochen zu hause
mit drei kindern war schon heftig wenn
man zwei granaten zu frauenhaus da muss
man eben auch wieder arbeiten ich meine
das kann man auf dauer vier fünf monate
durch szenische auflage im ersten
schritt geht es demnach vor allem darum
den chinesischen markt mit nachschub zu
versorgen das heißt dass die sukzessive
aus der kurzarbeit wieder rauskommen
das heißt auch dass wir glauben dass wir
ein gutes angebot haben und dass wir
verlangen nach mehreren wochen und
monaten dann wieder in einen normalen
betrieb übergehen nicht mehr autos
produzieren als nötig das ist die
herausforderung in vielen bundesländern
dürfen autohäuser wieder öffnen aber
statt ansturm herrscht flaute
hinzu kommt dass viele auch noch
verunsichert sind was soll ich jetzt tun
dann ist ja auch noch die motoren
variante diesel nicht diesel elektro
wann die weltweite auto kauflaune wieder
anspringt ungewiss schätzungen zufolge
werden 2020 allein in deutschland über
eine million autos weniger verkauft
meine einschätzung ist die größte krise
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg man muss sich
damit auseinandersetzen dass in
deutschland kapazitäten abgebaut werden
im automobilbereich sowohl bei den
anlagen
als auch bei den mitarbeitern und zu
fordert volkswagen eine staatliche
prämie für den kauf eines neuwagens auch
vw will in dieser woche seine werke
langsam hochfahren
aber ob die autoproduktion je das
vorkrisenniveau erreicht ist fraglich
eigentlich wäre heute ein ziemlich
aufregender tag für viele junge leute
ihr start ins unileben denn den meisten
bundesländern beginnt heute das
sommersemester
normalerweise würde das heißen
überfüllte hörsäle und studenten cafés
vielleicht noch die suche nach einem
wg-zimmer erste bekanntschaft mit der
mensa auf jeden fall viel gedränge und
viele begegnungen im corona semester ist
alles anders sylvia bleßmann jetzt über
einen mehr oder weniger digitalen uni
start
das große audimax verweist die rund
34.000 studenten der tu berlin starten
das sommersemester digital von zu hause
dafür haben ihre professoren und
dozenten in den letzten wochen rund 1500
lehrveranstaltungen aufgezeichnet
vorlesungen und technik seminar arbeitet
um sie offline anzubieten
wir werden auch mit streams
experimentieren um den online live
kontakt zu den studierenden zu haben und
zu schauen wie sie das ganze annehmen
studierendenvertreter elias grünewald
weiß dass nicht jeder mit laptop kamera
mikrofon und super internet ausgestattet
ist studieren heißt auch streiten
diskutieren manch einer sorgt sich ob
anwesenheit online überprüft wird viele
fragen und forderungen das messer darf
nicht als fachsemester zählen um weiter
in den bafög anspruch zu garantieren
prüfungen müssen rechtssicher abgelegt
werden können um den studienerfolg zu
garantieren es muss klar sein wie man an
digitalen lehrveranstaltungen sinnvoll
teilnehmen kann wenn man die technische
unterstützung dafür nicht hat gut 80
prozent der bisherigen
präsenzveranstaltungen kann die tu
berlin digital anbieten
viel schwerer ist das an der universität
der künste kreative wie
schauspielstudenten können nicht nur vom
computer arbeiten sie müssen raus wenn
sie nicht auf die bühne können müssen
sie andere orte finden
ihr professor weiß dass er die gewohnten
räume verlassen muss unser weg ist der
körper die übungen mit dem körper im
öffentlichen raum also in meiner
perspektive kann
im moment jede bushaltestelle eine bühne
sein virtuelle lehre ist für viele unis
ein neustart dieses sommersemester wird
grenzen und chancen für die zukunft
aufzeigen
auch großbritannien hat das virus fest
im griff aber da war ja noch ein thema
der brh exit die scheidung mit der
europäischen union ist ja unterschrieben
jetzt aber geht es darum wie es
weitergeht mit europa und den briten
am ende des jahres einen harten bruch zu
vermeiden heute gab es neue
verhandlungen aus london yasin herrlein
das mit den exit verhandlungen war ja
von anfang an keine einfache sache jetzt
das ganze nur per video-konferenz das
macht es nicht leichter bei der ersten
runde anfang märz saß man sich noch
gegenüber chefunterhändler david frost
liest inzwischen verlauten
großbritannien werde am endgültigen
austrittstermin zum 31 dezember
festhalten
eine verlängerung der übergangsphase
werde es nicht geben selbst wenn die eu
darum bitte boris johnson hat den ruf zu
wahren als diejenige der den br- exit
liefert und da gibt es einige in der
regierung die der auffassung sind dass
kogit 19
die ideale fassade bietet negative
folgen des praxis für die wirtschaft zu
kaschieren
der premierminister erholt sich indes
von seiner corinna erkrankung ist also
nicht allzu präsent wenn es jetzt
weitergeht mit der zweitwichtigsten
frage was die zukunft des landes
betrifft nach der korona krise und bei
dieser sei der premier auch nicht so
richtig bei der sache gewesen so die
scharfe kritik in einem ausführlichen
artikel in der sunday times mit dem
titel 38 tage in denen großbritannien
ins desaster schlaf wandelte unter
anderem lautet der vorwurf sich in der
entscheidenden phase zu sehr auf dem
brett konzentriert zu haben
britische landwirte lassen mittlerweile
erntehelfer aus rumänien einfliegen
damit diese britische arbeiter ausbilden
und angebautes nicht auf den feldern
verrottet geradezu ironisch erscheint
diese initiative war doch ursprünglich
eine der großen triebfedern des brh exit
den zustrom aus eu ländern einzudämmen
am zeitplan der bcr exit verhandlung
will london also erst einmal festhalten
ausgang ungewiss
ein crooner zeiten mehr denn je und
jetzt weitere wichtige nachrichten an
diesem montag nach drei wahlen in einem
jahr und zwei fristverlängerungen ist
dass sie israel endlich gelungen eine
neue regierung zu bilden
israels rechtskonservative
regierungschef benjamin netanyahu und so
ein oppositioneller rivale benny gantz
haben sich auf die bildung einer großen
koalition geeinigt
zunächst solle netanjahu als erster
dreieinhalb jahre lang das amt bekleiden
und dann von ganz als premierminister
abgelöst werden
unsere korrespondentin für israel ist
nicola albrecht nicola guten namen das
klingt jetzt einigermaßen kompliziert
was heißt denn das für die israelis na
ja zunächst einmal kam die nachricht
einerseits überraschend heute abend denn
das gezerre war ja schier endlos um
diese koalitionsbildung wochen lang hat
man verhandelt immer wieder hat man
verkündet dass man sich einig sei und
dann war man sich doch wieder nicht
einig am ende hat sich wohl der
amtierende premierminister netanjahu in
den strittigen punkten durchgesetzt
das heißt er bleibt vorerst anderthalb
jahre premierminister und das obwohl ihm
gerade der korruptions prozess gemacht
wird er es nämlich jetzt nur für ein
paar wochen wegen corona ausgesetzt
außerdem soll er sich ein vetorecht
ausgehandelt haben bei der besetzung von
richter
wenn ihr ganz wiederum hat jetzt diese
konzessionen sehr viel misskredit bei
seinen wählern eingebracht mit anderen
worten er ist für mich ein eher
schwacher vielleicht leicht zu händeln
der koalitionspartner und netanjahu hat
sich am ende wieder einmal hier in
israel die macht gesichert
notstandsregierung nennen sie ist
einheitsregierung nennen sie es aber es
wird noch viel streit in dieser
regierung geben das ist jetzt schon vor
prognostizierte im prinzip vor bestimmt
und mal sehen wie lange sie hält und ob
es nicht doch noch irgendwann wieder die
vierte wahl gibt sagt nicola albrecht in
israel dankeschön ein verbrechen in
kanada macht fassungslos und gedreht
auf ein als polizist verkleideter mann
erschießt mindestens 18 menschen
die ersten tötete er in einem kleinen
dorf im osten des landes zwölf stunden
lang verfolgt ihn die polizei dann durch
die provinz nova scotia unterwegs feiert
der 51 jährige täter immer wieder
offenbar wahllos auf seine opfer an
einer tankstelle wird er von der polizei
gestellt und erschossen
sein motiv ist noch unklar rund 200.000
dieselfahrer haben einem vergleich mit
volkswagen zugestimmt und erhalten jetzt
je nach modell und alter des fahrzeugs
zwischen 1350 und 6250 euro
im gegenzug müssen sie auf künftige
klagen verzichten
die frist bis zu der man sich dem
vergleich noch anschließen kann ist
verlängert worden
bis 30 april und noch eine nachricht für
alle die mobil telefonieren wer den
anbieter wechselt die nummer aber
behalten will muss ab sofort weniger
zahlen die bundesnetzagentur hat die
gebühr dafür gedeckelt auf höchstens
sechs euro 82
bisher waren das oft auch mal bis zu 30
euro
und dann müssen wir heute über das
wetter reden seit wochen hat es kaum
geregnet die waldbrandgefahr ist in fast
ganz deutschland erhöht und die nächsten
tage soll sie noch weiter steigen
erste brände gibt es bereits meistens
noch kleinere besonders heftig ist
dagegen die lage in gummersbach in
nordrhein westfalen direkt neben einem
der stadtteile brennen etwa 50 hektar
wald mehrere anwohner mussten bereits
ihre häuser verlassen
für weite teile der stadt gilt die
anordnung die fenster zu schließen und
britta jäger ist für uns live in
gummersbach ots die situation im moment
also der einsatzleiter der hat uns hier
noch einmal gesagt ja einen brand
solchen ausmaßes das hätte er in seiner
cousine kompletten feuerwehr laufbahn
noch nie erlebt wir reden hier von
ungefähr 100 hektar waldfläche davon
sind ungefähr 60 prozent betroffen
das bedeutet es gibt schwelbrände und es
gibt auch viele offene feuer zunächst
einmal ging es darum die menschen hier
in den umliegenden dörfern und in der
stadt zu schützen
es wurden auch mehrere häuser evakuiert
und jetzt fliegt hier permanent eine
hubschrauber hier hin und her
zwei wasserwerfer sind im einsatz und
die umliegenden bauern hier die haben
auch ihre gülle fässer gefüllt und
bringen jetzt das wasser in den
gewässern hierher die feuerwehr sagt das
war nie eine frage des ob sondern es war
eine frage wann so was passieren würde
denn es ist einfach viel zu trocken und
nicht erst seit diesem jahr und dazu
kommt noch dass sich eben durch diese
bürger auch der borkenkäfer ausbreiten
kann und der borkenkäfer der tote bäume
und totes sehr trockenes holz das fängt
auch eben sehr schnell feuer
und das ist eben nicht nur hier das
problem sondern in weiten teilen
deutschlands aus gummersbach wird jäger
vielen dank
und jetzt ganz anderes thema gegen ende
dieser sendung haben wir diese bilder
hochleistungssport in besonderen zeiten
und im wahrsten sinne des wortes das
hier sind victoria und carola aus
norditalien finale ligure ihr match geht
über 25 meter und quer über die straße
training für vor und rückhand bei sehr
gute mindestabstand muss man sagen nur
wenn der ball verloren geht dann heißt
es treppe runter und treppe hoch hält
auch fit
das wetter ist nichts für die freunde
des hochhaus tennis morgen kommt ein
sehr starker zum teil stürmischer
ostwind details hat gleich katja
honnefer
der kollege claus kleber im heute
journal um 21.45 mit fragen hans hessens
wirtschaftsminister was bringt der
korona flickenteppich ich sage danke
schön für ihr interesse gern bis morgen
aber erst wo immer das geht in allen
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren hoch
odilo bringt ostwind und die gefahr von
staubsturm wenn der ostwind nämlich den
lockeren ackerboden über die straßen
treibt und damit die sicht behindert es
ist staubtrocken denn der regen fällt
ganz woanders nämlich hier über dem
mittelmeer
bei uns dagegen kommt kein regen runter
in der ganzen nacht nicht meist ist es
klar und vor allen dingen richtung
mittelgebirge und auch ihrem osten
sinken die werte in richtung
gefrierpunkt dort droht bodenfrost
milder bleibt die nacht zwischen der
nordsee christ und dem bodensee mit 9
bis 5 grad auf morgen klettern dann die
werte an der mosel und auch am rhein auf
20 bis 24 grad sonst werden meist 15 bis
19 grad erreicht zwölf grad sind es an
der ostsee 14 stunden steht die sonne
morgen am himmel von sonnenauf bis
sonnenuntergang einzelne wolkenfelder
oder kleine quellwolken stören da
wirklich kaum mal was mehr stört ist der
ostwind denn der ist ziemlich stark zum
teil sogar stürmisch windstärke 8 ist
möglich 70 kilometer pro stunde
und dieser wind der treibt auch die
waldbrandgefahr in höhere höhe
morgen gibt es eine extreme
waldbrandgefahr hier in berlin in
brandenburg aber auch in teilen von
mecklenburg vorpommern niedersachsen
hessen und baden württembergs und
ähnlich geht es dann auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter schönen abend noch